Robert Habeck ist vom Amt zermürbt
deswegen suchen wir heute einfach einen
neuen so wie er früher war ein
nachdenklichen Zweifler und
stillenpoeten quasi das Gegenteil von
ihnen
also weder ist Robert vom Amt zur Müritz
sondern er zerbrechtigt hat und nach den
Kopf da braucht man niemand neuen suchen
wir haben the best
mit dieser Meinung steht Claudia Roth
alleine da deshalb ist heute Casting
Zeit wir möchten den frischen Robert
Habeck wieder wo ist der wer wird
Germany's next Robert
wir suchen hier den neuen Robert Habeck
wer könnte es werden Robert Habeck
ist ja verbraucht man sieht ihm die
vielen Nächte mit Christian Lindner an
ich habe auch viele Nächte mit Christian
Linda gehabt haben
fröhlich aussehen kennen sie denn jemand
der sich hier eignen würde als neuer
Robert Habeck
Robert Habeck vielleicht eher so Anton
Hofreiter dass der normale zweite
Karriere
die Hessen schon mal ob sie dafür
vielleicht in Frage kommen ein das
brauchen wir gar nicht testen
Sie wissen selber ne können Sie
vielleicht schon mal den typischen
Robert Habeck Blick üben so ein bisschen
verführerisch in die Herzen der
Zuschauer von unten dem Robert habe
Blick den verführerischen in die Kamera
aber okay sie sind schon mal nicht
vielen Dank schade wir brauchen einen
neuen Robert Habeck wir brauchen keinen
neuen wir brauchen einen neuen Robert
Habeck nicht ja doch da war von der
Schritt vor Ort
vorbei das ist ja ein Schatten seiner
selbst
ja sehen Sie sie erkennen ihn schon
nicht mehr wieder nein das war aber
gerade wirklich
da hinten steht da also so durch ist
Robert Habeck Robert macht es super und
der wird das weiter super machen und ich
bin froh mit ihm da zusammen zu arbeiten
wir sollen ihn aufmuntern nicht anlügen
das ist das ist kein anlügen das macht
das wirklich großartig unter diesen
beschissenen Zeiten der neue Robert
Habeck ist das nicht eine Weltsensation
ist doch Quatsch Anton Hofreiter winkt
auch schon dem neuen Hoffnungsträger zu
hier
Herr Hofreiter komm mal sie sind sich
doch auch sicher oder das ist der neue
Robert Habeck wir haben ihn gefunden und
zweifelhaft
man sieht es doch oder es ist eine
Sensation
früher auch nicht gemacht also sie
müssen einfach ein paar Kalendersprüche
raushauen
nein nichts gegen Kalendersprüche was
war das noch von der Zeit
werden
da bin ich Philosophie
ich träume nicht Dein Leben lebe es
träume nicht dein Leben
denn wir sind in der Realität
sehr gut ich bin beeindruckt richtig wer
gewesen lebe den Traum der FDP aber ich
lasse das mal gelten nein Danke und
jetzt muss ich arbeiten macht's gut
Leute noch einen Gutschein von der
heute-wochenende mit Christian Lindner
damit sie wieder der alte wäre
Robert Habeck freut sich also auf ein
Wellness Wochenende mit Christian
Lindner der Mann muss wirklich schlimme
Tage haben und damit zurück ins Studio
[Musik]
[Applaus]
oh Gott der Dreh für die